les étudiants de france ont
souvent au centre du débat
politique dès que l'on parle du
voile intégral au nom de la
construction des mosquées
publicis healthcare propose un
documentaire exceptionnel en
trois parties
pour dépasser les idées
reçues et regarder en face dans
ces circonstances
18 16 équipes
dimanche à 10 heures sur
facebook 5
public sénat - servir le
portail d'information politique
dès à présent vous pouvez
suivre l'actualité politique et
parlementaire en temps réel
converser réagissez participer
tous les contenus du site et
toujours la chaîne public
sénat en direct 24 heures sur
24 comme un symbole le plus
souvent que les autres
en accès gratuit 10
vance
l'ancien premier ministre
dominique de villepin l'un des
critiques les plus sévères
pour nicolas sarkozy pourtant de
la même famille politique
dominique de villepin vous avez
même retrouver votre carte ump
dominique de villepin donc et
notre invité bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté
c'est notre invitation je crois
que vous aimez les défis dans
cette émission vous aurez trois
fois l'occasion si vous plaît
de faire vos preuves
preuve par trois avec eux dans
un instant dans un quart d'heure
laurent joffrin qui viendra vous
interroger sur votre mouvement
république solidaire qu'elles
sont nous serons aux
propositions puis terrain
perrine tarneaud de public
sénat vous interrogera sur
euros même sur votre caractère
enflammer une donnée importante
dans votre parcours ai-je votre
cheminement
politique dominique de villepin
d'abord le blocage sociale et le
déblocage de
l'approvisionnement en carburant
un double défi évidemment pour
un exécutif pour le
gouvernement pour le président
de la république qui répète
l'ordre et la fermeté que
pensez-vous de la réponse
réitérée par le chef de
l'état lors du conseil des
ministres ce mercredi
l'ordre la fermeté de son
talent indispensable
nous avons trop souffert au
cours des dernières années
d'une perte d'autorité de l'ue
alors pourquoi ne sont pas
sensibles à cette exigence
le chef de l'état à raison
puis les débordements
les violences santini acceptable
de la même façon que le
blocage du pays le peut pas
quatre toléré dans un état de
droit
ce qui est important
c'est que cela s'accompagne
des gestes qui permettent de
trouver une porte de sortie
à la crise en quelque sorte
nous sommes
au milieu de dunes réforme des
retraites
il faut faire en sorte que cette
réforme aboutissait n'est
indispensable m pour que
l'ensemble des français qui ne
pensaient pas que
pour une fois la fermeté
pourrait faire passer une
réforme en france
c'est une vraie question à de
la réponse n'est pas simple je
ne peux que vous appuyez sur ma
propre expérience pour eux
j'ai essayé de répondre
à cette interrogation
il n'y a pas de bonnes réformes
qui ne soit juste
la réforme des retraites a
co-présenté par le
gouvernement n'a pas atteint son
point d'équilibré
on le voit bien
sur les bornes d'âge
le passage de 60 ans à 62 ans
donc report de l'âge légal de
la retraite
c'est très bien
encore faut-il que ce soit juste
pour tout le monde
canteleu
quelqu'un a commencé à
travailler à 18 ans
l'équipe
sera amené à travailler 44 ans
olic idée
sa retraite à taux plein est-ce
que c'est juste il ya un
dispositif vous le savez est
prévu pour les carrières
longues avant
18 ans
né à partir de 18 ans et 19
ans ses 44 ans non car en trois
ans
de la même façon pour ceux qui
à deux dixièmes pour le
barrage
le passage 65 ans à 67 ans pour
liquider sa retraite sans
décote à taux plein
nous savons que ce sont les plus
précaires et en particulier les
femmes 50% des femmes ont des
carrières incomplètes ce sont
plein de petits plombs
à la skieuse
c je lance aussi aidé à des
aménagements qui ont été
apportées le gouvernement
déroulée à aller plus loin et
aux mères de famille de trois
enfants
mais je veux que je suis
sensible aux gestes qui ont
été réprimées je prends en
compte
ce que les différences de la
réforme
dans notre monde d'aujourd'hui
tous les pays européens
qui sont entassés dans le
processus de réforme
paris - plus de mesures beaucoup
plus dures que dans notre moto
sur les retraites
opposés cette exigence de
justice comment david cameron
fait des réformes probable
terre
il y a un sentiment de justice
et cela fait passer
la réforme comment guérard
choix d'air
appris par minute
les mesures les plus difficiles
en allemagne
cette année avec le sentiment
de justice et la vérité - le
ps a cependant critiqué quant
aux échos dominique de villepin
qui a incité le gouvernement
cet homme c'est à la fois une
méthode il est certain que
dans cette affaire
il ya le sentiment chez beaucoup
de français qu'il a manqué le
temps de la négociation
qui n'a manqué du temps et
c'est pour cela que je vous fais
une proposition aujourd'hui
le compromis ce n'est pas le
groupe
dans la vie sociale française
le compromis c'est au contraire
et aujourd'hui dans la crise la
bonne voie au sens premier le
compromis pourrait être
1 deux points help
je suis parti comment sensibles
au fait
kepler les femmes seront les
principales victimes du passage
de 65 ans à 67 ans si le chef
de l'état
mais c'est de recevoir
les partenaires sociaux
et de donner une semaine
supplémentaire à la réforme
j'écoutais gérard longuet
rivière
le président du groupe
au sénat devient un pays il a
dit clairement
tous trois jours
c'est pas ça
va-t-il remettre en cause la
réforme vous dites
doudoune semaine
et à partir
2 le look d'une volonté du chef
de l'état de recevoir les
partenaires sociaux
et d'ouvrir ce temps de
négociation pour trouver une
vraie réponse
au problème de ceux qui seront
les plus pénalisées
par le passage de 65 ans à 67
ans
je crois qu'il ya il y a
le permettre aux partenaires
sociaux
d'éviter look
contournement
des positions prises
les principaux syndicats car le
risque aujourd'hui c'est un
durcissement
en dehors des syndicats
c'est le débordement c est la
radicalisation a déjà en
voyant un double contournement
celui
syndicale
par le billet
des salariés qui il ne se
retrouve pas dans cette réforme
celui des jeunes
et celui dans certains secteurs
on le voit dans le secteur des
transports dans le secteur
pétroliers
qui elles sont prêtes à en
découdre si l'on veut évitez
ces excès
il le faut
montrer que cette capacité d
écoute
je pense que 2007 retraité
cesse cette semaine
supplémentaire un élément les
musiques qu'on compare
il ya le sentiment et puis j'ai
vécu cela
comme premier ministre
qu'on peut jouer chopin
oui qu'en jouant sur quelques
jours de plus on n'arrive à la
semaine de la toussaint ne
l'oublions pas
la semaine des as tout ça
c'est la semaine
anniversaire
des émeutes des banlieues
une période fortement
symbolique évitons
ne pensez pas que le calme pour
revenir à l'occasion de cette
rencontre est la question
sociale des retraites ces joutes
la question santiane des
banlieues
nous aurions alors une situation
particulièrement difficile
alors vous dis ok bien sûr
votre expérience de premier
ministre dominique de villepin
on pense bien sûr au blocage
rénal sur le succès en
grand-angle en 2006
dans ce que nous écoutons
peut-être que vous souhaitez
fondamentalement au fond de
vous-même peut-être
que nicolas sarkozy et la joute
car l'échec sur la liste de
l'unesco de ceux déjà nombreux
à droite et là ce serait la
raison de la chaleur si tel
était mon sentiment
je ne mettrai pas en garde
nicolas sarkozy depuis de longs
mois
sur l'ensemble de ces questions
c'est partager son expérience
c'est prendre le risque être
entendu
c'est donc
le souhaitez en l'occurrence
que les choses puissent
s'améliorer
et quand je dis depuis trois ans
nicolas sarkozy le
déséquilibre institutionnel de
la france entre le premier
ministre et le président
républicain et dangereux
quand jeudi la justice sociale
dans notre pays plus dangereuse
être un moment donné il ya
peut-être plus de bonne
volonté dans ma bouche
que dans celle de beaucoup
de responsables de la majorité
partie par la baisse des
schémas de bonne volonté
vis-à-vis d'un v6
jeu je peux j'affiche pas bonne
volonté dans la vie de la
france vis-à-vis des français
je souhaite que l'intérêt
général préval
et je suis consciente du fait
que dans l'attitude de certains
responsables de la majorité il
y a
parfois
et c'est une faiblesse
la volonté de caresser le chef
de l'état dans le sens du poil
la flatterie l'esprit de cour je
dénonce dans un livre qui va
paraître prochainement
mais face
à notre pays lors du cpe
le contrat première embauche
dominique de villepin de les
jouer le durcissement dans un
premier temps
en ravanche de recul et des
points d'abord si ce scénario
est immuable
aujourd'hui par exemple baissé
il n'y a pas de fatalité une
réforme juste et perçue comme
juste
il va jusqu'à son terme
la radicalisation d'aujourd'hui
qui s'appuie sur le sentiment
d'injustice
le sentiment d'injustice il est
évolutif quand j'ai lancé la
réforme du cpe lévis majorité
de français qui soutenait la
réforme exactement comme la
réforme des retraites
et puis peu à peu
les histrions t volume épais la
majorité de l'époque se
diviser or aujourd'hui on
constate que la majorité était
en visant la réforme des
retraites une grosse différence
la majorité de l'époque m'a
pas soutenu
et les tunisiens aujourd'hui ces
différents l es tunis en
façade
la vérité je suis au contact
des cellules souches au contact
des parlementaires et même de
certains ministres
je sais
combien il se pose de questions
je sais aussi que ce sont sûres
par crainte
de l'attitude du chef de l'état
et pourtant ils ont tort
il faut dire la vérité nicolas
sarkozy il n'entend pas
ni de la part de ses conseillers
ni de la part de ses ministres
ni de la part de sa majorité
le chef de l'état aujourd'hui
qui sonné il est coupé
des réalités et ce déni de
réalité on le voit sur les
retraites
comme dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines je prends un exemple
la lutte contre les déficits
nous avons raison pour lutter
contre les déficits
le chef de l'état doit savoir
que la croissance est en cours
nous aurons une mauvaise année
2011 l'événement termes de
croissance
qui dit au chef de l'état
qui est fou éviter
de microblogage à la lutte
contre les déficits en
n'oubliant la croissance
moyennant quoi alors
c'est le chômage sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français
qui sera en question alors
2 que pense nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui c'est
je cède mais je suis mort
politiquement pour 2012 certains
médecins dans son entourage
proche ce tracé cette politique
et de renoncer certains
pourraient faire défaut de
l'averse savez il ya toujours un
grand honneur
il est toujours de bonne humeur
et puis il ya toujours du
crédit à 2000 que ceux qui
savent
évoluer s'adapter souligné
personne ne demande que l'état
devrait prononcer la réforme
des retraites
ce qu'on souhaite
c'est que cette réforme soit la
meilleure possible pour les
français
et c'est là où il y a
une erreur d'aiguillage
la réforme en france
on a tendance parfois à la
considérer que c'est une erreur
de la droite c'est une erreur de
la pensée de droite
c'est de penser que pure la
réforme elle est au service
d'une ambition partisane
de subtiles on décidé de la
fed
la réforme elle est au service
nicolas sarkozy la réforme est
au service des français la
bonne forme
c'est donc celle qui est juste
pour tous les français leur
accès partiel qui est bonne
pour le mp ou pour nicolas
sarkozy
de ce point de vue il ya eu une
erreur d'analysé la droite pour
les filles celle d'appâts
l'idée était rouillé
du réformateur droit dans ses
bottes
le réformateur droit dans ses
bottes qui est mort depuis
longtemps non alors il ya
peut-être une ouverture qui se
dessine via des amendements
enroth au sénat
la perspective d'un vaste débat
sur une réforme systémiques
commandé pour cent des
retraites avec pourquoi pas un
passage
allah retraite par points est ce
que vous pensez que c'est un
geste là qui pourrait
notamment
ils se réconcilient pouvoir les
tester l'été c'est sa
demi-volée de choses moi et
j'ai pu j'ai dit la même chose
les amendements tout à fait
jeudi j'ai dit les douches
courtisé
l'ouverture
parce que c'est injuste
vis-à-vis de ceux qui
souffriront le plus des mesures
de rage
c'est une nécessité et il faut
par ailleurs donné
plus d'audace à cette réforme
le principal
il reproche qu'on pourrait faire
outre la justice cette réforme
c'est qu'elle manque d'audace
cette réforme
ce n'est pas une réforme pour
les trente quarante prochaines
années c'est une réforme
comptable
mais il nous permet de sortir de
l'ornière
court terme
mais en 2008 nous avons
rendez-vous pour de nouvelles
réformes parce que cette
réforme aura épuisé son
action
sans compter que le financement
n'est pas encore complètement
prévu
donc on vous dit
il faut une réforme
qui soit adossé à un vrai
projet de société
pour que ce projet de société
sont au rendez-vous l'idée
d'une réforme par points
par compte notionnel on a une
bonne idée cela donnera plus de
liberté la possibilité une
retraite à la carte et une
deuxième idée indispensable
qu'il faut rappeler c'est la
nécessité d'adosser à cette
réforme des retraites une vraie
politique ambitieuse de l'emploi
vis-à-vis des jeunes qui sont
victime du grand scandale de
notre société et vis-à-vis
des seniors
le chef de l'état peut décider
d'un geste fort
pour répondre à l'inquiétude
les plus précaires dans le
passage de 65 ans à 67 ans
richie mccaw parallèlement
donner une perspective à cette
réforme
or nous serons tous gagnants
c'est cela une bonne réforme
que le gouvernement selon le
jouet
oui la demande d'essence a un
qui s'exprime dans les
stations-service les demandes
d'ordre également contre la
mobilisation sociale avec les
pensées vous parlions de la
visite
de brice hortefeux
à lyon où les de nouveaux
incidents étaient contents de
presse que le 1er mai je suis
tout à fait convaincu
de la nécessité de la fermeté
pour défendre notre état de
droit m c'est vrai qu'il ne faut
pas accepter que les dépôts le
pétrolier soit bloquée et nous
devons faire en sorte que les
français puissent monter au
filet a été fessée pour le
gouvernement une fois
l'intérieur oui mais
mais plus loin
attention
on choisit des moyens attention
toutefois des symboles
misrata est
c'est d'abord le ministre de
l'ordre république
et ce ministre-là
il n'a pas vocation mais c'est
un point sur lequel je me suis
opposé souvent nicolas sarkozy
il n'a pas vocation allez être
pour elle le veut forcément
toujours en permanence le
premier flic de france
la misère d'ailleurs c'est plus
que ça c'est un symbole c'est
un beau jour comme le premier
film le toulousain s'est blessé
mais c'est la cfa par jour
c'est pas toujours la bonne
image
en période de crise
le ministre de l'intérieur doit
être le garant
de la sortie de crise
c'est dire
kim doit prendre en compte avec
responsabilité c'est évident
de sortie de crise et donc
choisir les mots
choisir les symboles choisir les
gestes
et faire en sorte
quand toutes circonstances
nous soyons soucieux de
modération
il ne faut pas faire le jeu de
la radicalisation nous tombons
pas dans le piège de la
surenchère
veillons à ce que le touriste
et ses diverses
abolition
et que les forces de l'ordre ce
soir en permanence en situation
de
contrôler la situation
le contrôle de la situation
c'est un contrôle des mots
c'est un contrôle des symboles
et c'est un contrôle de
l'action alors on note quand
même que
l'antisarkozysme est un de mes
auteurs
comme dans les manifestations
les cortèges c'est aussi
le nôtre dominique de villepin
on va en parler dans un instant
en allant plus loin sur vos
propositions cette fois
laurent joffrin le directeur de
libération qui est là nous
rejoindre mais d'abord on va
suivre ensemble marie brémaud
sur les traces de république
solidaire alors que le
politiquement
ouvrez partir en devenir
et en mouvement d'idées ou de
l'inde selon un nouveau on
regarde
lara allet présumés
dominique de villepin était
accueilli par 6000 personnes
telle une rock star la selle est
importante il s'agit de montrer
que l'explosion
ministre a de nouveau à place
dans le paysage politique
français
quatre mois plus tard au coeur
du très chic 8e arrondissement
de paris au fond de cette petite
pour les locaux de la
république solidaire
l'ambiance est nettement plus
intimiste la secrétaire
nationale aidé de son
assistante modestement bat le
rappel des troupes nous faisons
la démonstration que finalement
pour l'année de la somme
système laisse brièveté et
beaucoup d'énergie nous
arrivons à mon avis c'est
beaucoup plus que que les grands
partis
en quête d'adrénaline être
demandée villepin
et visiblement ça marche dans
les fermer dans les banlieues il
va manifestement là où ils
pensaient être mieux reçu
qu'un certain nicolas sarkozy il
y avait comme un parfum le bazar
dans le prétoire et razzano n'a
pas trouvé très bien sourire
à la caméra poignée de main
médiatisé mais que propose de
lecce premier ministre à
travers son mouvement
qui n'est pas un parti mais qui
en a toutes les prétentions
éléments de réponse le 4
décembre prochain date à
laquelle se tiendra le premier
conseil national du mouvement
l'occasion d'afficher la force
ou la faiblesse de la
république solidaire
voilà donc ce sera la preuve
proposition que je comprends
bien dominique de villepin alors
le froid arnaud de rejoindre
joueurs et les membres de
la question de son choix en
europe mais je vous ai écoutés
beaucoup de tension
la chienne chose qui me frappe
c'est que
si on vous emmène voulu votre
image votre voix
les combats ne suis pas martine
aubry françois hollande me
françois chérèque mais
combien de texte
ce sera la même chose
celle que l'on retrouvera tout
de légaliser leurs efforts
devant des journalistes en place
à des journalistes une campagne
je pense que j'ai joué dans la
région soit hollande hier que
léger côté martine aubry
revient tout le temps les mêmes
choses non
la maire de lille dans le bas
par les joueurs parce que
il faut négocier la réforme
balladur alain gravel
les grandes banques dans le
monde entier je vais gérer mon
âge je préconise que je
préconise un compromis je ne
suis pas sûr qu'à gauche
ce soit le compromis qu'on
cherche
je l'aï position dans la queue
pour voter les pourparlers
d'adhésion syndicale lors de
l'encan pas tout
les forces politiques m son
talent angle droit
sur la question des retraites et
moi ce que je propose justement
c de couper la poire en deux
cissé non une stratégie pour
les gens mais une méthode très
vilain mot il suffit d'un mot
monsieur le président du style
sarkozy
négocier
et puis tout devient possible
moi je montre que je montre le
jeune joggeuse douanes montrent
le chemin du but sur quoi et sur
quels points et comment on
pourrait le faire passer par des
affairistes et particulièrement
la suspension de la réforme et
la sepanso une semaine mois moi
je je prends en compte
le cadre dans lequel le
gouvernement que je respecte
même si je ne suis pas d'accord
sur l'approché initiale faire
mais aussi peu le mal à rentrer
dans la légalité une fois zip
il ne demande pas un président
qui est une demande parentale
et je pense que dans ce
cadre-là on peut trouver une
porte de sortie dans l'affairé
de tous
et je m'appuie nature de frein
et sebha
la démarche
du parti socialiste a plus que
ce que la plupart des syndicats
je m'appuie sur une vision
parce qu'il faut bien essayer de
s'appuyer sur une vision de la
france
je suis convaincu
que dans les dix douze
prochaines années
nous allons est confrontée à
des échéances
sur les déficits
sur la compétitivité
française
sur l'éducation sur la
politique étrangère qui vont
nous obliger tout à fait nous
à trouver un chemin
comme un talent peut-être que
vous ne rêvez pas il est
actuellement
button compte que du gauche
mais là vous exactement le
contraire de ce que dit tous
plus plaisant presque peu plus
carré mais voyez-vous ce match
est un homme d'expérience et
l'asie et de l ump comme comment
on peut être le pays dirige
actuellement le contraire de
tout ce que dit ce parti
il ya maintenant le frère de 5
ans déclarent croyants ou pas
dante et laurent joffrin
il faut prendre en compte le
fait
que la vie partisane étudierait
du christ
les parties très précis ce qui
l'agacé et le moment où le
complexifier la pénurie de los
angeles lakers alors
et c'est pour ça que je crée
un mouvement c'est un mouvement
de rassemblement république
solidaire qui est totalement
indépendant des partis
et qui s'appuie sur le ambitions
d'initier une nouvelle démarche
politique il serait temps que
vous at-elle surpris dans la
réalité du 21e siècle
la france et je le pense très
profondément
et prise de rendez-vous sous
majeure et notamment le risque
de décrochage de la
mondialisation
et le risque d'abaissement si
nous voulons éviter cela il
faut coller la réalité
c'est-à-dire chaque fois que
nous pouvons faire un pas en
avant même si sa part n'est pas
l'idéal je pense que la refaire
la réforme des retraites telle
qu'elle est fini s'il n'est pas
l'idéal
mécontent
essayons d'avancer donc je
privilégie une démarche
pragmatique de compromis sur
le combat idéologique qui
s'organise dans notre pays
depuis des années et qui
parallèlement il dépasse le
droit des femmes
non je ne regrette rien votre
mouvement en somme c'est très
simple qu'elle voulait dépasser
la démarche aux listes cela
démarre ce rassemblement
c'est-à-dire chaque fois qu'on
peut faire un pas
eh bien on prend ce pas
et on va de l'avant
mais si blanc donc lieu vous
avez un mouvement que vous avez
une personnalité une
expérience de tension pour lui
ou plus si entente que
peut-être un peu louche
candidat indépendant autrefois
à peu près ce que laisse
entendre oui 6 non qualifiés le
finlandais de franchement on se
dit franchement les autres et
qu'on ne saurait
partie prenante à cette
élection il faut dire que je
fais mon égard mais c'est bien
pour ça et c'est pour ça que
je veux dire un peu plus de
folie dans leurs démarches je
ne fais pas que taquiner le
goujon buteur jeudi que je
saurai poker
de la campagne présidentielle
parce que les idées que je
défends parce que l'engagement
qui est le mien
film d'animation aujourd'hui
avouez haut-rhin sur ce débat
et vous porterez vous-même donc
l'alternative démantèlement et
à la caméra vga je porterai
l'alternative est ce que
woerth le jeu politique
fera que je sois candidat nous
verrons bien mais aujourd'hui
vous empêcher de la ppo mais
aujourd'hui je vois pas je dois
l'avouer
13 est-ce que cette épée de
damoclès cela vous plaise
en e l'appel à peine sur le
prophète certaine que sa femme
cela freine votre élan je le
dis et je me réfère à ce que
j'ai dit depuis le début
cela
de même aucun impact et il
n'aura aucun impact sur la
démarche de l'afp
le 6 si le nombre de candidats
pour n'en citer que quelques-uns
jusque-là un peu plus crédible
vous aurez
contre lyon un candidat de
gauche
on peut imaginer un but d'école
d'ingénieur policiers ont donc
pour être élu il faudra battre
comme de gauche
donc vous serez plus
mais est-ce que le condamné ali
bongo uob le renard un hibou
quelqu'un de gauche vous avez un
anglais le seul salut
vous serez obligés de leurs
alliés
le pnb sarkozyste en lambeaux
puisque sarkozy aura été
détruits entre temps
et donc que i je vous souhaite
de droite quoi
mais bon je je je n'ai pas peur
des étiquettes quelle qu'elle
soit mais ce qui m'intéresse
cette affaire
d'un côté nous avons une
gauche
qui pour eux peut-être tentés
par le durcissement était donc
se déporte vers l'avant
selon la nature du conflit
d'âge que ce sera la miss
cross-canal ce que ce sera
martine aubry ségolène royal
françois hollande nous allons
voter mais nous pourrons pas
exclure son mouvement
la droite par contre c'est une
évidence aujourd'hui et se
durcit
et nous voyons depuis le
discours de grenoble se déporte
sur la droite
liste c'est pas que sarkozy veut
un accord sur les lieux
ces essais d'une manière
générale type de droite de
droite demandent si ce n'est
pour l'heure personne souhaitant
hormis ma modeste personne
s'opposer à sarkozy et personne
de dix ans nicolas sarkozy
l'activité de ce qui se passe
dans notre pays
spontanément
le calcul c'est de se déporter
vers la droite
l'espace qui est ouvert
entre eux le positionnement
actuel du chef de l'état au
sein de l'ump
ce que sera la position obligé
de la gauche contenu
le de l'extrême gauche je ne
sais pas si noir mais beaucoup
plus que le centre
est-ce que les gaullistes sont
au centre
l évolution de recrutement du
stade montois chrétiens sont
systématiquement son est-ce que
les sociaux-démocrates sont au
centre laurent joffrin
la bataille est passé du centre
c'est la bataille de la france
et de l'intérêt général
nous avons
des partis
aujourd'hui ils sont
galvanisé par idéologie
et qui oublie les français
moi ce qui m'intéressait les
français cette expérience vous
même annoncé pour ce qui est
ce travail l'arrivée de
jean-louis borloo à matignon
mais l'idée n'est pas mauvaise
langue je n'ai rien annoncer du
tout je fais une distinction
oui fondée sur la mémoire que
j'ai de la vie politique
quand jacques chirac est arrivé
pour cent quand jacques chirac
alors en 2002
pourquoi j'ai décidé de
choisir un communiqué c'est pas
facile
il fallait choisir sa majorité
comment faites-vous pour choisir
au sein la majorité sans vexer
personne il a lancé une petite
compétition qui m'a demandé
d'organiser j'étais secrétaire
général de l'elysée
j'ai donc demander à chacun des
impétrants
2 le remettre sur une copie ce
que serait sa politique
sorte de discours de politique
générale
ce que seraient les hommes et
les femmes auxquelles ils
feraient appel et chacun a rendu
sa copie nicolas sarkozy
jean-pierre faure
les jeux était un petit pays
puisque j'avais prévenu
quelques jours avant
jean-pierre raffarin que ce
serait pour lui le premier
ministre
nous assistons à la même chose
à une différence près ce qui
s'est passé sur quelques jours
avec jacques chirac se passe
aujourd'hui sur quelles valeurs
ce qu'il faut ce que
alors décrit jean-louis borlo a
reçu
avant l'été une feuille de
route
gillett
non pas de réfléchir mais de
se préparer
à un moment de sa vie sa nuit
de noces que je suis bien
informé dans tous les jardins
maillot de lannemezan les
espions déloger le colonel
libyen 2010 je connais bien
qu'on est dans l'eau espèce
dans l'élan donné par les
dirigeants de l'om
jean-louis borloo n'est pas un
homme qui a vocation à se
mettre en avant s'il n'a pas
reçu de paiement elle peut donc
pas dans mon état de fait
réfléchir parce qu'il ferait 6
les têtes
malheur il a occupé le gazon
anglais en terminant que les
autres les autres
elle qui aujourd'hui sont sur la
sellette mais il pointe de
l'aiguillon que le fait que les
journaux mettre bout à bout les
autres
la demande
différentes de réfléchir à
ce qu'une forêt